Let's first take a look at the contents of an HTTP Request. First there's
the Request Line which typically indicates first,
a method of request. Where typical methods
get to return the content associated with the URL. A Post which sends data
to the server and a Head Request which returns, typically, only the headers of
the Get Response, but not the content. It's worth
noting that a Get Request can also be used
to send data from the content to the server.
The request line also includes the URL which is
relative, and may be something like index.HTML and it
also includes the version number of the HTTP protocol.
The request also contains additional headers, many of which
are optional. These include the referer, which indicates the
URL that caused the page to be requested. For
example, if an object is being requested as part
of embedded content in another page, the referrer might
be the page that's embedding the content. Another example
header is the user agent, which is the client
software that's being used to fetch the page. For
example, you might fetch a page using a particular
version of Chrome or Firefox. And the user agent
informs the server which, client software is being used.